Jennifer Parisi s'amuse avec son petit
Owen mais derrière son sourire se cache
un stress immense elle n'a pas trouvé de
place en garderie pour son poupon de 10
mois et ses prestations de congé de
maternité ont pris fin je mets un
parental j'aimerais retourner soit aux
études ou même au marché dans le marché
du travail mais c'est pas possible que
j'ai aucune place à la gare de riz sans
revenu Jenifer s'en remet maintenant au
programme d'aide sociale une situation
difficile à accepter mais c'est dur sur
mon moral puis mon ego si j'étais
toujours une personne très indépendante
travaillant puis là je me retrouve
vulnérable ce matin quand j'étais obligé
de faire la pile j'avais beaucoup
d'émotion
ça y est beaucoup me chercher
[Applaudissements]
sont des espoirs est aussi partagés par
de nombreux entrepreneurs de la BD
chaleur qui voient le manque de place en
service de garde comme un frein au
développement de leur entreprise j'ai
perdu concrètement un très très bon
employé qui était venu s'installer ici
en région avec sa femme deux très très
bons talents et ils ont pas eu d'autres
choix que de retourner s'installer à
Québec faute de garderie
création d'horaires atypiques pour aider
la conciliation travail famille
difficulté de recrutement le manque de
place en service de garde aggrave encore
davantage la pénurie de main d'oeuvre à
chaque fois qu'on a un emploi qui tombe
en congé parental on sait jamais quand
ça va se terminer c'est ça la réalité là
on n'a pas le choix d'être conciliant
mais c'est
hommageable pour les entreprises ça crée
un stress six humains aussi pour ces
jeunes familles là
c'est très préoccupant
c'est un grand problème là pour
l'ensemble des entreprises du territoire
de la baie des Chaleurs à la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de la baie des
Chaleurs on espère que les
préoccupations des familles et des gens
d'affaires se tailleront une place de
choix dans la reine politique comme
c'est un enjeu tellement important pour
notre région et pour les entreprises
l'avaient des chaleurs on aimerait ça
que ça prenne une bonne place là dans la
campagne électorale dans son petit
appartement Jennifer parisien n'est pour
l'instant pas convaincu que la détresse
des parents trouve suffisamment écho
auprès des candidats locaux pas vraiment
beaucoup j'entends plus ce matin ces
réseaux sociaux je vois beaucoup les
mamans les papas qui mettent des
annonces mais pas beaucoup
[Musique]
alors que la lutte s'annonce serrée dans
la circonscription de bonne aventure
l'enjeu du manque de place en garderie
pourrait devenir la question centrale de
l'élection pour les parents et les
entrepreneurs qui exigent déjà des
gestes rapides et concrets de leur futur
députés ici Isabelle Larose Radio-Canada
Carleton-sur-Mer